this is called ice this is what winter
in America feels like
nibsy on that slip
now slows scary pick up who I'm just
supposed to help them find jobs you must
be the guys from Somalia senegal sub
down did your luggage come down the
chute great where is your husband no I'm
not married I provide for myself your
survival skills are very impressive
thanks I'll call you tomorrow morning
and we'll start the job hunt I need your
help I'd any dangerous animals in this
area such as lions no there's no lions
hear your safe search store anyway I'm
not sure this seemed pretty traumatized
made my way to the border
I had 34 brothers and sisters and the
old and white one and she need to be
here with us you don't have an
appointment who do I have to screw
around here to see an immigration
supervisor me Thanks cupcake that's
gonna be a problem all flights from the
Kakuma refugee camp have been stopped
since nine eleven the program here has
stopped indefinitely she's a child
refugee of war you sure you're ready to
take this on definitely
you're being asked to make choices no
one should have to make I don't think
they're gonna make it if they're not
together I will pray for you get rd erd
it is as efficient there for you it
means great white car well it's better
than a lot of things I've been called
No
but
I like crap you can't just break into
somebody's house there is a reason you
do not have a husband okay thank you so
much